this is green Irish tweed comes in a
nice little grabbable hand bottle don't
use any of that okay hi I'm Charlie puth
and these are my essentials this is a
pretty standard issue black leather
notebook I've been writing actual notes
in notebooks since I found out I had
perfect pitch when I was 12 years old
it's just like my own little system of
just keeping my thoughts organized I
just write like either lyrics down in
this like every artist or I write stuff
like this down these are actually notes
when I'm layering harmonies I tell my I
just write down G B D F sharp B G rather
than write down the music notes which is
always the class that I failed so I just
write down the actual letters and sing
it this is my cell phone I use it to
record little and then I play the beat
back do a little it's like two tracks in
my mind because I can't do everything
sorry record one bit on my phone and
just kind of walk around like a like an
idiot just come up with a song that way
I also use my phone as a phone but most
of the time I'm either on voice memos or
writing little notes down I try and not
going to Instagram every second of the
day I think I've deleted that app like
five times already weird this is a
candle by llola James Harper it's called
the white coffee on Tita balcony it
reminds me of like a it smells like East
Coast in July like a like a summer in
New Jersey this candle actually travels
with me everywhere I'll put it on a
plane backstage wherever this is Creed
green Irish tweed I like the way it
smells I don't know a whole lot about
perfumes but I first discovered that
this was my cents at the Gramercy Park
Hotel where they had a store nearby
kind of just on a whim I was just
walking around New York in like
September so I just think of September
in New York every time I spray it
it's you know 60 I thought this would be
a nightmare bringing up this actual
piano to GQ so I just printed this out
and cutted like a little school project
first vintage synth that I ever
purchased 1982 I think it came out and
the warmth that this piano this
synthesizer rather possesses you just
can't mimic human assembled lots of
humanistic feeling in it that just kind
of is the icing on the cake when I'm
making a record for myself or anybody
so the Juneau 60 this is the kind of
underwhelming packaging a bit this is
fresh soy face cleanser I've been told I
have a very oily t-zone I don't know
what that means I think it has cucumber
in it I went on Amazon and saw that this
was marketed for women only I thought it
was interesting because it seems to work
on I've recommended it to like 15 people
and they've all loved it and all guys
too so it's nice this here is a Rolex
Oyster Perpetual Daytona I've been told
that these are kind of hard to find this
was given to me as a gift I'm not even
gonna pretend that I know a lot about
watches
I like Rolex because the weight is nice
and this one which is the absolute
antithesis I got this for myself on my
25th birthday I said okay I'm gonna get
myself a watch I went to Rolex calm and
this was the first one that popped up
this is also in an oyster perpetual day
date the new style and it has a green
face with greens my favorite color so I
really like this one but I can't wear it
everyday this I can wear every day to me
I'm always gonna look at this watch and
I'm gonna be like okay wow I've at 25
years old I got myself for something
pretty significant it's the kind of like
you know my quarter life inspirational
thing something that I always get to
look at on my wrist and be like oh I did
a good job that year these are the San
Heiser HD 650 headphones I use them to
mix every record I got these in college
my parents got these for me there's not
a whole lot of EQ to them they're very
true to sound flat headphones and
they're kind of worn in there the colors
faded there
cracked a lot but they're very special
they've traveled everywhere with me tune
what they lack in flair the outside they
make up the sound inside when you put
them on and mix we don't talk anymore on
these mixed attention on these see you
again one call away Marvin Gaye how long
done for me
I love these I'd highly recommend this
is a green shirt I don't really love to
think about what I'm wearing in the
morning I just like to throw a shirt on
over a beat or something really simple
like that kind of like what I'm
literally wearing right now I'm not like
a fashionista but I just like shirts
that are like like old vintage shirts
like this is a vintage Hermes shirt
actually made in France and I just liked
it a lot and it's flowy and fun and it's
pretty much it
these are loafers I went to Catholic
school and you were required to wear
shoes like this I used to dread wearing
these but now they're very much in style
these are quite fancy these are saline
from Paris and they give you a nice lift
I like the double tassels kind of rare
unconventional it definitely pulls
together my own aesthetic like I'll wear
an Air Force but I don't really love
wearing sneakers with jeans I just have
like a little weird I don't know how to
explain it
so go for the bit of a fancier option I
think I got the idea doing this from yg
I always saw him wear dress shoes with
long socks I thought that was cool now
I'm gonna put him back on and I think
that's it once again this is Charlie
puth and these have been the 10 things
that I can't do without hope you've
enjoyed it those headphones are really
good I would really recommend those
headphones too
[Music]